Hales gum bros my name is Pierre de
Parma
I'm so excited to cuss today I get to
play some more inside for you bros this
is an incredible oh my god what just
happened why can't I hear did I turn off
my head a bit what an intro there it is
my headphones were off okay did I just
die so I rented a lot of you comments
and it's really interesting to hear your
thoughts and theories on what's
happening in the game because it's not
really that obvious and a lot of you
bros pointed out the fact that how do I
die here a lot eros pointed out the fact
that the people who were after us didn't
actually shoot us they it look like they
had like tranquilizer darts and when you
die from them they actually just grab
you they don't kill you
unlike the dogs though they kill you I
don't know also I'm it an idiot for not
realizing they was chickens whatever
holy [ __ ] while I definitely died there
okay but please do keep leaving your
thoughts and theories in the comments I
think it's really interesting to discuss
these kind of things I think I have to
keep this box as a cover or some [ __ ]
what is happening here hopefully [ __ ]
just gonna run for it I'm just gonna run
for it Oh
oh my god what is this place
I'm so confused by the universe but it's
so intriguing okay I assume we have to
okay we have cover now what is that a
shock wave or some [ __ ]
it seemed like it go go go go go oh no I
should have stopped there tonight
[ __ ] out I had to pull it towards me
of course I'm an idiot okay
let's give it another go I'm sorry
alright I'm sorry the box was just there
to tell us that we die from the shock
wave
I thought we were gonna use the bucket
it's really cool sequence there it is oh
I'm just gonna run for it that was cool
that was really cool
okay so what is this lever do it stops
the machinery where do we want the
machinery to stop
I assume somewhere where we can jump on
it like perhaps there let's give it a go
maybe I'm wrong
oh we needed us a shield huh okay I'm an
idiot I I should have been obvious it
wasn't even in the same plane as us it
looks like a coffin it kind of makes me
anxious okay let's stop it no that's too
early
in here let's wait for the shockwave
what is this play is like a power plant
are we at war that would make sense
I don't know oh my god so maybe a lot of
you bros make comments about the title
inside and you know there was the
parasites but how does that relate to
the oh my god and then how does that
relate to the the fact that people
trying to control this are they alien I
don't [ __ ] know this sounds so stupid
they're not I'm just just thinking out
of that all right
so Michael told me who played the
through the whole game not I want to
spoil it
he didn't spoil anything but I don't
want to say anything in case someone
okay now how did we get past this part
it's a little tricky
think maybe we just have to time it oh
did you see that go go go
the music changed that's so cool
oh my god this is so intense
oh my god go go go go go go oh go little
boy that was cool
oh my god I love that can be still into
timing we're still not safe no I missed
it that was perfect
come on oh there it is ah we did it that
was really awesome oh my god
I love this game
and I died [ __ ] me cuz I open I'm an
idiot although that this looks very
curious where are all these people
sitting here why I can't pull the lever
[ __ ] oh my god what what is this place
it really just sound alien you can't mi
not stupid for thinking thinking man
well it looks like this thing moves like
oh it does move okay sorry were you
yelling at the screen about that this is
so curious like what is this place looks
like a harbor but why are we being
attacked by shock waves can I move it
here I can
okay we're still safe whoa
well safe maybe not so safe actually
okay more timed action okay how does
this move very Street okay it stops
there for a while that's our only chance
oh that was so close
well okay we got to time it better
we gotta time this oh that's awesome
come on dude run yeah whoo that was
amazing
let's keep going and we're safe here
I never feel safe in this game never
so I'm sorry such a beautiful background
noise background guys are myself alright
down a rep down it doesn't seem very
safe I can't believe we're going farther
down I'm so sick of going down oh my god
I mean still alive we're still alive
we're still alive we're still alive we
got to get out of this elevator though I
think we got to get out of this elevator
somehow oh we definitely got to get out
of this elevator Oh God come on dude
get out I can't what do I do
oh I have to open the game of course
come on holy [ __ ] I died right by the
surface no I did it oh you okay there
buddy
you don't look so good no don't go back
in Jesus you you're right there buddy
come on man we're in this together okay
new area what do we get
oh it's one of these come on buddy
I'll do an extra swing just for safety
there we go okay
it's a puzzle ha ha ha all right let's
keep that swing in then
oh no it's cat dammit i reconned it
maybe not
oh my god that makes me anxious Jesus
Christ okay we did it oh my god
stairs no more water I just feel like
the mermaid girl is gonna come back I
have a strong feeling that that's what's
gonna happen why do I call her a mermaid
Joe she's clearly not oh all right
down we go this guy is been through a
lot I don't know how we're still alive I
think this guy could use a hamburger
right about now we gotta time this oh
come on that's never gonna work
oh my god that she is she looks like she
has a parasite in her could that be it
hey lady wake up alright what happens if
we press this an elevator okay
I can do that jump and this of course
not sure I understand why I would do
that oh I get it I get it
again it I get it I get it I get it now
I'm an come in annoyed okay so we got to
make sure that first we came up here and
then as late as possible we press this
[ __ ] sake and we timed it right like
that
boom nailed it okay that's pretty cool I
know why I make everything so
complicated tell me shut up okay here we
go
now we can cool puzzle I enjoyed it
thank you very much I'll be going up now
see you later mermaid girl sorry that's
just her name now terrible name Oh God
Oh God oh hello hey hey [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah no no no no I don't like
you I don't like you
ah don't touch me daddy oh he looks down
alright lets you know let's just go this
way okay [ __ ] it damn it we have to go
there alright [ __ ] it
cuddle Kiril up hey buddy how you do and
then
I was gonna go with me
there's something here
ah [ __ ] mermaids
sorry god damn that scares me thank God
there was a rope there god we gotta go
down again I call that [ __ ]
I knew the mermaid Carla was come back
hello Killa sorry this game makes me so
anxious oh I can go up here I can go out
there I never want to touch water ever
again we'll go to the beach later and
I'll be like no I'm not going there's
mermaids freaky hairy ladies I don't
know what to call them Jesus this this
looks like it would move I don't think
it does I think we just have to do
another kind of hakuna you know what I
mean
kind of care lap oh my god
hey good good talk oh she hates me she
really does hate me see I don't even
know what I did
oh I gotta get higher I didn't see that
okay yeah gotta get high you gotta get
high to get low come on
oh my lord oh my god I god I get
goosebumps like this scares me more than
horror games I'm not kidding
oh no again please for the love of God
can you not touch me oh no oh no what
happens if i press i go what why am i
going this way oh I get it I get it it's
it's weighted with this wing
it just goes back and forth is that it
maybe we can change the tracks well that
was god-awful okay so what happens if we
go here
I'm just gonna go ahead and press this
and then I'm gonna die this the mermaid
move if I move like this a chain
distract her I'm just gonna assume it
does now he doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't [ __ ]
there's definitely something with the
chain going backwards that's gonna give
us more time she doesn't follow us
unless we're in the water
so now she's there
okay let's give this a go it's gonna
make me want to die a horrible death but
oh oh yeah oh oh hello there oh my god I
didn't know that was gonna happen
of course I planned it all accordingly
oh my god just says I planned that hey
more water that's pretty good [ __ ] water
this is not gonna work that thing is
gonna break and I'm gonna die but not
today
[ __ ] yeah all right doing good
hell yeah hey what do we have here you
want to touch the wall you own it you
want to do that mmm can we push it maybe
we can push it Oh what is developers
hate me goddammit
how does she even get in here is there
another one of them sorry don't want to
be your friend
it's our wall here damn it can I get up
nope nope not gonna do that not gonna do
that you know what not going to do that
it's gonna dip my feet a bit
I go up god
god damn it this game is not helping my
fear of deep water [ __ ] that [ __ ] sorry
alright I'm sure she's lovely before she
had some kind of I don't know
alright go go go go go go go okay go go
go go Co Co Co Co Co Co Co Co Co Co Co
Oh God breathe breathe neither breed
need to breathe oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
alright glad we did that
hey box how you doing and now we're safe
hey no more water please
that's all I'm asking
stop stop what is she doing stop
wiggle what is happening oh my god she's
choking me let me go
why am I still playing if I'm dead
what's happening now what is happening
here it's getting darker oh my god
light a dot is that a chicken oh no oh
no what has happened it's coming from me
oh it's the mind control thing it's the
Hat
it caught me wake up dude
this is so unexpected I'm I can't move
Wow
we just woke up and we're choking I
think we can breathe on the water now
something injected in us we have the
same power as the mermaid lady now I
think so at least I mean she could have
just helped us all alone well I don't
mind the water anymore the fishes are
following us why it's like the chicken
Singh alright they're cute you know what
fine follow me I'm the king of the sea
now this is like an office something
I am so curious I want to find out more
of what is happening you know I'm so
intrigued oh my god
it looked like it was built underwater
man have you guys seen the movie under
the skin this really reminds me of it
just when he's under the water the black
water
I recommend the movie if you want to
watch something really [ __ ] weird and
I just keep thinking if they spent too
much time in the water it's gonna be bad
what is this
it really does seem like oh my god here
we go can we pull it oh we just got to
hold it
let's do that again yeah there's another
one on the other side I see it go
got it holy [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god oh
okay we're swimming upwards we're still
in the water I think I see the circle
are we okay on the surface nada we were
so far down
oh man this is gusting
so when we went down in the water the
lady kept trying to pull us down but
then this machinery got us and I think
it planted something in his
we I think we have to pull that thing
hi
you see it looks like they're trying to
capture us it only seems like we were
invaded by aliens or some [ __ ] and they
set all this up to kind of like uses all
this slaves
but it seemed like humans in the
beginning oh god I [ __ ] up that's why
I'm so confused abide it's either that
or some kind of group
trying to collect dissolve and trying to
use is all for their own gain
okay we got to pull this thing
this is the shadow
No
it is but I'm an idiot look at that hey
ha ha I'm thinking aliens more and more
I don't know why am i I feel stupid for
saying it because technically we haven't
seen anything but there's just so many
unexplained entities I guess and it does
remind me a lot about half-life 2 and
the alien invasion in that in that game
oh my god that was so close I think we
can do it now
yeah let's go for it I don't know if I
can come up here though
I can't the light stopped coming no it
didn't we might have to pull it down
even further
someone a [ __ ] now again all right
let's keep going oh no I think we should
be able to just stand directly
underneath it
okay there we go we did it now last call
there it is can we do it I don't want to
risk it I'll wait I know
all right come on we spent a lot of time
putting this thing here I'm not gonna
mess up now you'd be well pissed at me
if I [ __ ] up now you gotta have patience
in this game
I know I don't have it but I just do
nothing Oh God
am i that much of an annoyed what Oh No
yeah damn it what'd I do wrong
no it doesn't go down further I think it
does oh come on
yeah damn it now you're pissed anyway
I'm pissed too all right I'm shaking so
angry no that was my own fault
got to give the game some price in that
actually a lot of like dying in this
game is not necessarily frustrating it
usually just teaches you what you did
wrong and then you can apply it it's not
like oh the game [ __ ] up man that was
so dumb I think I need to line in that
hole there that's the name of my porno
well what is not a problem anymore I
think hey fishies y'all coming with me
buddies yeah it's a party down in the
bottom under the sea I have to sing it
another sea did it the fishes are
batting me not in the sea I think that's
the lyrics not 100% sure um no I it was
just a landing all right sorry fishies
got to go back God got [ __ ] to do I
wonder what happens if we meet the
mermaid girl now she's still gonna be a
threat to us or not I don't know this
looks like a threat however whoa whoa
whoa what is this what is this this is
weird what no I want to see what was
there
okay I guess we go back up okay
perhaps we open this scheme is very dark
but I love the contrast between light
and dark in this game it's really cool
guess that's what made limbo famous it's
black in my saturation or whatever sad
but we do get a little better read on
his sweater and other elements oh here
we go
let's see where this takes us
not far enough we we pulled this I want
to check this place it looks like people
in the water upside down this is so cool
it really is I think we need to go to
the other c-level but how I don't know
actually I realized I have to end this
episode here thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I absolutely
love this game I'm so amazed check it
out yourself please do that support the
red developers and if you're watching
this playthrough and I'll see you bros
with another episode tomorrow and as
always stay awesome rest yeah [ __ ] yeah
what do I do now
oh Jesus Christ